yeah hello and welcome
the session of some blitz games let's
see if we can get a game here with the
somewhat slower blitz time control it's
not bad to have one one of those in but
experience shows it's not so easy to get
a game in this time control get one
okay the nickel I'm
and you know poem never played him Oh
III
not so bad actually huh okay it doesn't
refute the Sicilian but it is
interesting this is the idea to wait
until black plays g6 and then you employ
the setup something that you probably
maybe have seen in my games I've played
this with black against 1c form this is
not the idea really now white plays a
grand prix attack with the fairly used
to some way three
you want to play Bishop a Jew and be
ready to play aged form that is them
yeah that's the real idea he played you
differently now again this is just a
Grand Prix
yeah White has this Bishop a to option
now but yeah it's nothing
special
hmm
mmm I have this
I have this opportunity here to to take
on your forearm but probably Teague with
the night
yeah what I'm after what I'm wondering
is if I double on the C file and then
trade like D takes D takes Queen takes
this ending could be quite good actually
because both his bishops look a bit odd
now come on he will have to sacrifice a
pawn to avoid the Queen trade it's
possible I mean move the knight now
somehow but
something that will not be objectively
correct I guess he's thinking about it
because probably he wanted to play more
when attacking game yeah now I go b6
that was my point
idea Bishop a six and a rook to d8 and
both his bishops look bad if you play C
form to allow Bishop b2 land as a -
Bishop is dead and I have also some
ideas to play against the e4 pawn with
Bishop e7
be careful that one of the data bishops
don't get too bad in this position will
seem Bishop a6 is also an interesting
move that I could
maybe plane now I'm definitely playing
it
because the thief
is completely impossible strategically
speaking and now how does he ever get
the bishop on hu into the game
okay now and I know do I Castle
queenside
or just rook da da de looks completely
normal you can also think about
okay let's do this first this is a good
move basically no matter what I wanted
to say Knight a5 intending Bishop c4 is
also interesting
you
should be too
also
let's do this it's interesting
if I could trade the LightSquared Bishop
sand put a knight on to see form it
would be great I mean his pawn structure
is really bad
I wonder if c4 is a movie actually
[Music]
okay so let's do this
to going Bishop b1 now to avoid the
trade I don't think so he's actually
doing this um I was wondering about f5
in this position if this could be an
idea trying to fight for the light
squares even more
name a plane 85
oh okay
Jim okay 97 to c6 or the other one
I think this is okay I have Bishop a6
and potentially night c4 anyway
okay now King e7
you know
it's not easily fighting it further for
the D file
a 694 looks good okay yeah I expected
something like that he has to UM YUM get
active in some way can I just sit in
wait the whole time but how do we how do
we handle this
even if I've is interesting here
you
but Rico age five
you
not sure not sure how to do this
you
age five is just going age three I don't
know but then I can actually know this
is actually right I can do this age
three I can take on the one take on g4
and then go gage three so I can actually
enter
and that should be
enough to be fine
I mean I'm fine anyway I mean just a
good way to continue the game yeah he
shuts it down this is of course possible
hmm
yeah I feel I'm not doing this correctly
yeah honestly I mean it looks really
nice somehow but it doesn't feel like
I'm making any headway dominating those
bishops but difficult to see how I'm
actually winning the game
crime
trade
- I don't quite see how I'm making
progress
94 it's not really a threat but
you
angling 45 here maybe he goes f5 here
No
this is a good idea at all but I'm not
quite seeing how I'm doing something him
to
you somehow expand my position and
someone will do something positive about
it maybe maybe just a pawn to c4 here
right it could be an idea
yeah I saw this a bit too late
that he has this because takes takes
this Knight takes e5 at the end
has some
also night h4 now in this position
pressurizing g6 Wow
it was difficult but I managed to miss
play this pollution
three he still has a dead piece on a to
which I played it so terribly that this
position might be completely okay for
white if not more it's remarkable
that I don't quite believe in why would
she do that
no no there's no pressure anymore
activates the III Bishop which is good
but a2 is still a dad
maybe I'm well
is ideal
absolutely not understanding wise idea
93 you know what is he doing
you
and then Bishop before at the end set
the point
like it
I can't take it to it
you
King of 3g5 drops with check
you
what a weird gainer I did not understand
anything here right I mean that was
really bad
from the beginning when it was more or
less a strategically winning position
you
yeah I'm going to
take the queenside first him maybe I
don't know not not so much time so
and second-guess everything here
probably
and when I'd be seven I cannot
six because of 98 ha
okay that was not very intelligent
Jesus
my god
you
you
do I get to the H pawn somehow I need to
end it I need something with concrete
counterplay
you
you
and night 96 unfortunately
position
you
what a game
so is he promoting I don't know come on
anything else anyway so okay h2
okay
it's not getting getting the ayah the
funny position near covering f7 and it's
not entering can go to e5 F 4 and then
I'm dropping back
no let's push the
a
pawn
you
now let's see I mean I'm getting
upon him
and just one name
[Music]
you know what
get here
you
know what
it's it's very weird that I'm winning
this game after all but
I completely miss play dead like
completely yeah I just want to have a
quick look there because I'm not really
don't really understand what I watch
what was happening here
akia white is basically done that's it
just strategically lost this position
because of this Bishop on b1 and yeah
the engine wants to play this f5 moves
that I thought about I was more
concerned the computer says 85 if White
has to play e5 I'm playing this of
course then this is just completely
disastrous as I even get to d5 square I
mean yeah all the pieces are fantastic
this can also go here and here and so on
but I wasn't I wasn't quite convinced
that he I'm sorry that he has to play e5
but maybe I'm just not understanding
things I thought this would be maybe a
bit annoying but yeah the engine is just
taking this and of course I'm
threatening immediately the checks iam
oh that's true
that is that is basically winning then
it's the way I played this this wasn't
so all that clear oh I took and what was
particularly bad I think
some how I played it from here now I
already had this odd idea to play e5 but
he already can play a five and this
stood this is already gives him enough
play even though he still has the dead
PCM this already gives black give white
play I take and this oh man
I wasn't good and then later I really
was just busted
so here and then here f6 is just was
just bad I think
but I think I'm just played it again now
I mean this is fine
can I'd be seven seems to be better okay
but and as I'm interested in this as
well
and probably to doing something wrong
here entirely okay King c6 Bishop before
1996 instead of
okay but shouldn't this win somehow me
takes bishop takes so king D six wins
King t6 but
shouldn't this win as well
you
okay yeah I'm just wrapping the night
how silly is that I just go to see seven
of course
huh ah that is bad right and just go
here and this is it's just nothing Oh
play King d7 and now
okay and that should you say just -
million I just want to figure out okay
so here or 95 is not exactly difficult
yeah and this is this is all of a sudden
now this is made in aid
No okay Knight g5 was winning this is
not winning now it's winning again oh my
god yeah come on let's play
it's okay oh man yeah I should have
played a fight right this is something
that I mean I thought about it but I
didn't quite get it right um so Bill
Bailey I've VA okay together we actually
get a game or not
so got a couple of seconds to play the
move
alright this is a solid solid opening
actually Hawaii at Queen's Indian
reversed
to have them
if something special but well
some relatively easy to play
okay
mixes
this with the bird opening
you
I'm not sure about it
take
just ask him about you
to open I wants to keep this diagonal
open
understandable for sure
probably now we'll go back to be to the
bit costs a bit of time here all this
probably check on the sixer can actually
enter primo fields
you
oh that is actually true
mm that was ever there was a sloppy
player sloppy play by me
you
you know
I think I'm not losing a piece but
I I did not I did not see this
beforehand after Queenie five resource
five takes takes Queenie 5 and the rook
is hanging
and planned you know it was just i
blundered into this
now he has spotted
I played before first to Wheaton
it's a little bit but this allowed 92
it's so I'm not a big deal I think
or do we blame
how bad is Quincy five is that
terrible terrible move
Oh
[Music]
kind of interesting
after d4 I can take on c2
link
five Queenie three that gives me quite a
good Wow
very good amount of pawns can have to
latch that wouldn't cross my mind in a
million years it's not sure I mean maybe
it's not so bad which is like we can
have - why say woof
yeah I mean it it covers the porn but
still requires some
thinking outside of the box to come come
up with this so my idea is h5g 594
you
maybe no
not sure what is going to do
three cannot work I take and have I have
check on the age farm so this one okay I
don't get it
really or maybe the other continuations
felt even worse I don't know but I'm
this I'm just taking
you
now let's went to
me
downhill
for white
came it's night G for an option here
maybe not you form
no that looks good
now even even pawn takes is interesting
but doesn't quite work
now I cannot take III II but I can
cancel first
you
you know so a material up and a good
position on top there anything
particular that white is threatening
yeah I wonder if I should take the night
at some point just going to take it
just with heavy pieces the position
should be
straightforward just pile up on the eve
upon
and there is not
not much insight in terms of
counterplay i have root g5 check so d4
doesn't really do much
you
nice taking good amount of time him
you
now how do we actually win the game
chick
defies probably not so good
a bit of timing I don't need to
being much of a hurry
[Music]
Chum
and g6e has prevented huh it's still not
so easy to to move the pawn so I can go
g6 now
f-five preparing preparing d4 with all
this because now eform I can take
you
oops
oops
you
you
you
yeah yeah that was a bit bit Organa
blundered this f5 stuff but maybe it
wasn't so bad yeah so in fact g4 is not
a good move but it was lucky I didn't
really see that I'm not losing material
here the point is always clean v when
I'm attacking three things at once and
like winds and it was lucky I think
still I was a bit surprised that King f2
was played here he should play a 5 that
wasn't clear at all I mean I was just
saying okay f5 hmmm so check and I was
thinking I can probably play something
exactly what the engine is giving I was
thinking about this kind of position
where I felt okay this should give me a
fair chance is in a blitz game I've got
two pawns and the age trial I mean I'm
not surprised that the engines has white
is probably a bit better but okay I
thought it is interesting but that he
has to play I think King f2 that cannot
really work here after age five like
wins more or less okay so let's go back
to the
front page share of leeches and
look for a new game
now I believe it's difficult um to
improve the rating from here for me at
least
aerated opponents and it's really
difficult to gain points against 300 400
points lower rated players you only get
like 1 point or so if you win and
in case you really consider have a point
is like very costly one or losing even
yeah this line with Queenie to check is
quite interesting and important because
otherwise like would have no problem
equalizing in this line almost no
problems Knight c3 is also certainly
playable the interesting point is that
even after the Queen trade and White has
a pretty nice initiative here with the
IQ P it's not like the IQ p is Riccio
like has basically no way to put
pressure on the pawn and he has to be
farm warm concerned about his own King
oftentimes black needs to lose quite a
bit of time to organise and um this is
often enough for why to claim a small
but
certainly um yeah an advantage that you
can can can feel is there he's taking a
long time yeah I'm not quite sure what's
best sometimes they play a rookie aid
idea that looks very ambitious
how do you go now King f8
you
okay
you
I said it looks
because this just cost so much time to
put the bishop out and enter to a cost
more time because of 9595 then you have
to play Bishop g6 probably and you're
still not using your rook on a Jade
okay now I wasn't certain but I thought
that night b5 might be
a bit of a threat which maybe this is
not the case I'm going to do it
okay hmm I didn't think about this one
but okay this is actually not a problem
like if he trades him I'm not so happy
that my night is back on d2 but how does
he cover this now
I mean c6 96 is not really what you want
showing again that the bishop on f5 is
not ideally placed
maybe 98 yeah 98 backward chess
or maybe this could be the
the way to handle it and me me me Knight
b6 was possible okay now um how do we
how do we play here
he's going to place his six
but I can actually take on the aid yeah
rook takes 96
and then I'm attacking the rook and the
bishop so it would be at least
at least possible a team
oh then he has to move the bishop then
basicly
hmm
you
mmm it's not really it's not really
leading to much I think
I'm so going to do it
yeah I can pre move that basically I
have to play it anyway
so now rook and Bishop is attacked um so
maybe Bishop g6
yeah
I would have been nice to see the smooth
didn't see it
I mean it's not like it'sit's a big
problem but I would have liked to be
aware of it
would have been good
is actually still a problem because I'm
attacking b7 and the bishop
and here I can go looky one
retinic made
Ruki aids and then i have various ways
to win material
it looks best I think
the tech
it's actually really difficult to play
this position okay I'm giving him a
rematch why not I didn't give any before
because I wanted to look at the games a
little bit but don't think we've got so
much to check in this one
maybe
play something something else
I got this Banco repertoire on chasuble
there was my first
the repertoire
Jim
I think I'm going to play this but it's
not really fresh in my mind anymore it's
been a long time
since I've since I've wrote this
as I've written this
anyway
I don't really remember many details
you
interesting
came f4 what's going to happen maybe
you
yeah and it I need to get get something
more going on the beef farm
ad-lib
trade
made some some stuff what is that move
that looks odd
then the night is not protected so
you
should f4 night h5 is very embarrassing
yes to go to H form
no way you can think about Knight h5
even here
you
and
it's also c4 in this position and could
be would be interesting
but is going to play before against it
you
hmm
not not really sure
maybe this one for concrete reasons
like a fall and see form
often you want to not play a five
because after a four they might
establish a blockade on the light
squares but I don't think it works him
yeah I think it doesn't work running
because Queen d7 if I was hanging here
in this pollution
I'm threatening a four as well so he
doesn't have time to play a form
b5 is a pretty read move actually
what now
and now I just have a FOIA or I do I
have something better night h5 is also
not
and this is actually pretty good right
let's do this
that rincewind material I'm threatening
Knight f4 winning the night and the rook
is hanging so I'm not sure a four is
also good for blackbird
he has to somehow create an exchange
sacrifice out of this which is actually
an idea it's not like it's completely
bad maybe a form
the hope is to simply win the food piece
because neither fries
the secondary idea nay doesn't move the
rook immediately which shows that it
probably has spotted already he didn't
spot it okay
yeah this is just a full night weenus no
square
go to
protected
banco gambatesa is tricky
you
you
now it's too late
just too late I could have made an
exchange sacrifice out of it and this is
not objectively enough but yeah you have
to play a form okay the engine is close
to compensation yeah but I thought he
would have some but not that much
and that probably better is a four in
this position yeah I've thought about
this
well iid I had to feel him because this
is also very good for black but you kind
of [ __ ] you play you just play for our
material sometimes I care maybe doesn't
see it and then you win Amir Lim
interesting is that this also wins which
I didn't spot at all and it makes an
awful lot of sense okay so one more game
then I'm calling it a day for this
session
maybe just mix things a little bit
a six is not a bad line actually has
been played by
champion on numerous occasions
looks bit weird but it's it's again it's
not so bad
you
yeah normally after the trade of them
LightSquared Bishop splegg is fine in
such a structure in the cards but
yeah we'll see I would unfold so it's
going before very quickly
Oh
you
it would be very nice to have the night
on
six levels all always them um the key
maneuver from a black but his very quick
is very quick with us
we insight advance
I can do this but it's not a not an
ideal scenario or this blocking move
you
the backward c-pawn is not really a big
deal as I get the night to see for orbit
not sure if this was good for white as
before now could become um at least
slide weakness
put the Queen here
you wouldn't maybe him you know I don't
know trade first not sure this feels
okay I think this is six pawn is always
safely protected by the seven-night and
he has to worry about before and I've
got 9 c4 also coming I don't think I'm
better but it looks ok
I would the seem but how does he
actually handle this now if he goes rook
F b1 I can maybe just grab before
I don't see why not and if Luke FB one
is not possible what are you playing
sometimes it's good to have a night d3f
for whites to cover this pawn but the
queen is there so it won't work either
not entirely sure
what is doing them
you
yeah this is not winning any beauty
beauty contest status in the smooth rock
a - sorry look hey for I mean
No
to double on the e-file
yeah if yeah if you need to play night a
- something is wrong
you
maybe something like Quincy 293 and
oddly queen a queen bee 293 I have to
really kind of untangle here this
position
okay it's probably a similar idea okay
now I can play Knight c4 here but one
thing to keep in mind is that
if he goes Knight c3 I can actually take
before even though that could be a bit
of a bit of an awkward pin in any case
I'm going to play this first long story
short so that the knight has to move and
then I play Knights you form
you
'i'm 93 now let's jump in
so he cannot he cannot move the night at
the moment
and I would absolutely like to triple on
the a farm
he has night c-54 album
and
would we do this
you
you
yes still if I go here
okay three then
I'm threatening Queen a7
okay that's the counterplay
yeah and this it's a bit of kit so it's
gotta play
okay so let's say I take it
take it
okay
I only got 28 seconds
only now spotted that I'm actually in a
bit of a
bit of a time problem mommies it's just
not moving
yeah it is probably still a pretty bad
position okay it's a - force kind of
kind of a lot yeah the problem is it's
really um I think he played this a
little bit too a bit too superficially
here
so when Knight b6 here I think a5 or
just keep the tension might be better
here I don't have a problem I think the
b-pawn is just a bit weak and now 95
this leads no way I'm really after Queen
d6 it's a bit of a problem already and
Knight H who is it's just not working I
don't think so this is just much too
much disharmony that same night c4 was
maybe better but this is just so awful
you can maybe think about improving even
on my play but I think I think it's
definitely enough
and here you're just completely running
out of moves say I got Queenie 7 as the
engine confirms that that's really this
is hanging already if or might be under
pressure and I mean you cannot move it
can just cannot move your pieces if you
go here I can probably just take before
or Queenie 7 it where Queenie 7 is a
very strong move just now what what is
the Queen doing now yeah interesting and
that went downhill very quickly it's
surprisingly quickly ok guys hope you
enjoyed the video I think yeah I'll be
posting one tomorrow as well thanks for
watching